hacemos el repaso de los principales
medios de comunicación del mundo de la
mano de Marta Moya Marta Buenos días y
vamos a comenzar en nuestra revista de
prensa Buenos días Ángela vamos a abrir
en Europa las tensiones entre Italia y
Francia Son uno de los grandes titulares
es del día de hoy por el desembarco del
Ocean biking en Francia Finalmente y que
no pudo llegar hasta los puertos
italianos Francia ya permitió que la
embarcación atracara pero las relaciones
con Roma se han deteriorado en las
últimas horas cuéntenos que dice lemons
sí Ángela vamos a empezar por Lemon que
hace un repaso de lo último que hemos
conocido esta mañana no titula el barco
humanitario Ocean biking atraca en
Francia con 230 migrantes a bordo tras
tres semanas deambulando por el mar
llegó este viernes al puerto de Tulum
después de que la ong esos mediterránee
hubiera denunciado hasta en 43 ocasiones
al gobierno italiano que por favor le
dejara atracar en sus puertos y el
gobierno de la ultraderechista Georgia
meloni senegara además también se
comunica sobre el tema sí le parecían
hace un artículo que titula Ocean viking
crisis abierta entre París y Roma esta
noticia y lo que ha acontecido en los
últimos días abre un cisma entre las
relaciones entre ambos países y dice
este artículo además que es un flashback
brutal con lo que pasó hace cuatro años
cuando el gobierno Entonces el ministro
de interior Mateos albini no dejó
atracar al barco acuarios que al final
tuvo que atracar en España y Fígaro hace
una editorial que titula macron Atrapado
en su propia trampa Y es que El
Ejecutivo de macron dice este editorial
hace una cosa y la contraria al mismo
tiempo hace una semana estaba
denunciando a un legislador de la
extrema derecha por presunto racismo y
hasta hace unas horas no había permitido
al barco desembarcar Precisamente en sus
puertos Ese es el lado francés como
titula la prensa italiana Comencemos con
la República la República en su portada
empresa titula macron rompe con meloni
las tensiones alrededor del Ocean baking
desembocan en una crisis diplomática y
París califica a Roma de inhumana
También tenemos en la estampa la estampa
titula en su portada también impresa
migrantes Italia de sumana desencuentro
total entre París y Roma macron amenazó
con expulsar al embajador italiano en
Francia y además meloni podría preparar
un veto en el seno de la Unión Europea
con su homólogo húngaro Víctor Urban y
un medio que se consulta bastante y
corriere de la cera el correr de la cera
hace también un artículo en su portada
impresa en el que dice ruptura con París
sobre los migrantes el presidente macron
rompe con efecto inmediato un pacto
migratorio que se había firmado en el
seno de la Unión Europea para que
Francia acogiera a 3.500 migrantes que
habían llegado a Italia Hasta el verano
del próximo año y que en este momento se
quedan suspenso bien Vamos a quedarnos
en Europa y en la misma línea porque el
medio político ha publicado un artículo
bien extenso en el que habla de las
relaciones entre los altos dirigentes de
la Unión Europea que se encuentran en
sus horas más bajas si Ángela Este es un
tema bien curioso porque hablamos de
Charles Michel el presidente del Consejo
europeo y de Úrsula wonderley en la
presidenta de la comisión europea
recordemos que la comisión europea es el
brazo ejecutivo de la Unión Europea que
propone las leyes y Charles Michel el
presidente del Consejo es quien se reúne
con Los jefes de estado y de gobierno y
debate y que al final materializa o no
esas leyes No esas propuestas de leyes
las relaciones entre ambos mandatarios
dice este artículo de político están en
sus horas más bajas a un año y medio de
que acabe la legislatura y todo ello se
habría gestado o sea el punto germen de
este desgaste total de las relaciones en
abril de 2021 cuando se conoció ese sofá
Gate cuando ambos líderes se reunieron
en Turquía con erdo y solo había una
silla al lado de erdogan Charles Michel
se sentó en esa silla Úrsula wonderlayen
quedó relegada al sofá y acusó a Charles
Michelle de sexismo en la Cumbre del g20
ambos mandatarios de la Unión Europea no
parece que vayan a tener muy buena
sintonía porque Charles Michel se
reunirá con y hasta reunión no está
invitada wonderlayer porque bonder
Legend vetó a Charles Michel en una
reunión con narendra modi en junio en
Alemania en el g7 Y ese tema del sexismo
que vuelve y sale alrededor de
bonderlein vamos a terminar con una
noticia que grita viernes una curiosa
Tribuna del diario español el país en el
que se mezcla sexo y amenaza nuclear de
qué se trata si es una Tribuna muy
peculiar es la pública es lado sísec y
titula así la del fin del mundo
porque 15.000 ucranianos están a favor
de una fiesta sexual en caso de ataque
nuclear Y es que es un tema que ya se ha
venido bueno publicando varios medios a
lo largo de la guerra sobre todo a raíz
de La amenaza de Vladimir Putin en los
últimos meses acerca de la amenaza
nuclear y dice que a pesar de las
tensiones en el terreno y de La retórica
alrededor de la cuestión nuclear 15.000
ucranianos estarían dispuestos a
terminar su vida teniendo sexo en una
con 15.000 personas a las afueras
de kiev una que se llama
sketchevipcia y que se hicieran marcas
en las manos para no perder tiempo y que
supieran cada uno cuáles son sus
preferencias sexuales pues mire Este es
un viernes bien complicado con mucha
agenda noticiosa Así que gracias por
traernos a algo diferente en el panorama
Marta y le deseo feliz resto de jornada
gracias Ángela